Hello and welcome to this video on Blend Spaces.
A Blend Space is a tool that allows us to smoothly transition between different animations
based on some kind of variable or input, like camera speed, direction, or a custom parameter if you need it.
This is particularly useful for creating realistic character movements, like transitions from walking to running,
which we will be doing in this session.
So, here we are back in the project, and I'm in the My Animation Blueprint directory that we will be working in.
We're going to create a new asset.
So if you right-click and you come up into the Animation section,
you'll see that we have an option for Blend Space.
So if you select this, it's going to create a new asset.
Again, we're going to be asked which skeleton that we want to use.
We are using the SK underscore mannequin.
So I'm going to select the SK mannequin, and we have our Blend Space.
I'll name this My BS for Blend Space Walk Run.
I'm going to double-click on this Blend Space.
And this should bring up a window that looks a little bit like this.
Now we have the asset details down the left-hand side.
This will allow us to control how the Blend Space is set up.
We have a viewport in the middle.
This will allow us to preview the animation as it is being blended.
Underneath the viewport is a grid.
We can drag the animations onto this in order to blend them.
And in the bottom right-hand corner, we have an asset browser.
This will appear in numerous different places around the engine.
The main thing to understand is this will only display animations for the selected skeleton.
What we're going to do to start off with is we're going to be working only with the horizontal axis.
So we're going to start off by renaming this horizontal axis.
And we're going to change this to be Speed.
And once we've got that, we're going to change the maximum axis value.
Because we're going to input the speed that the character is moving at any one time
in order to determine the output animation.
So the maximum speed we're going to go up to in this is going to be 500.
So 0 is going to be our minimum axis value and 500 is going to be our maximum axis value.
Now, once we've done that, let's grab some animations.
So the first one that I want is going to be an idle.
So I'm going to search for idle.
And I've got a couple of options here.
I'm going to go with the top one.
So mm underscore idle.
I'm going to drag that in.
And I'm going to place that all the way over here to the left.
That's going to be in the bottom left hand corner.
And we're not going to be using the vertical axis.
So we don't need to worry about it in this instance.
We could place this at any point and it wouldn't really matter.
Now, next up, I'm going to select Run.
And you can see that we have mm underscore run underscore forward in our Asset Browser.
I will drag that in and I'm going to place that right down at 500.
Now, we have two keys, as you can see, as the small little diamonds on our grid.
But we also have this green cross.
That green cross is going to determine what animation we are previewing.
And to move that, we need to push the control key.
And that will move the green cross to wherever your cursor is at that moment.
So you can see if I hold this down, as I move it to the left,
it slows down and goes back to the idle.
And as I move it to the right, it speeds up to the run.
As you can see in the middle here, this isn't a terribly natural movement.
So let's add in one more animation.
Let's find walk.
You can see again, we have mm underscore walk underscore forward.
We'll drag that down and place that as close to the center as possible.
You can see that gives us a good walk cycle.
Now, I move the cursor around left and right.
We go from no movement all the way up to running with a walk in the middle.
So now I'm going to save this asset of my BS walk run.
And that's everything we need to do there.
We can drag this in and we can start using this at this point.
So let's have a look at connecting this up.
And to do that, I am going to jump back into the browser
and I'm going to select my animation BP.
Now, this is the first time that we've looked at the animation blueprint in detail.
So let's go over the different elements.
First of all, we have a viewport up in the top left hand corner here.
And this again is going to preview the animations.
In the center, we actually have the AmiGraph at this point.
Now, you can navigate around this by holding down the right hand mouse button
and you can drag and move the canvas around.
And again, much like any of the other blueprints,
if you right-hand click, you can search for nodes to add into it.
So for example, if I was to add in a boolean,
I would be able to drag in and connect up different elements like this.
We'll be working on this in a while.
The other tab that we have here is the event graph.
This event graph, as we've talked about earlier,
this is going to be where we will bring in different values
and we will process them in order to figure out the animation.
So the event graph is the logic that will process the variables.
The animation is going to be where we will plug in different animations
in order to create the output pose.
So as you can see here, we start off with just a singular node
and that is the output pose.
And whatever is being put into this
is going to be what is played on the animation.
So let's have a look in the bottom right hand corner
where we have the asset browser again.
Any of these animations are going to work directly on this skeleton.
So if I grab in the idle, drag it in,
you can see that we now have a node for that idle.
When I left-hand click on the little man,
I could plug that directly into the output pose.
And if I hit the compile button,
you can see it's going to display that animation.
So you can see it processing and running the animation here.
And this would work. So if I was to save and compile,
run into the level and run,
you can see now I have my character idling.
However, they're not playing any other animation when we move around.
So that's what we want to fix here.
Jump back in. I'm going to delete this idle.
And to start with, I'm going to use a state machine.
So let's create one and we'll discuss what it is.
So if you right-hand click,
and you search for state machine,
you'll see there is an option that comes up here that says state machine.
And I'm going to select this state machine.
Now by default, it starts off being called the new state machine.
But let's give it a name so we understand what animations this is outputting.
And we're going to call this locomotion.
So we know that this is going to give us our basic locomotion animations.
Now, let's connect this up
and double click on the state machine in order to open it up.
Now again, this is going to give us a different type of graph.
We will start off with the entry field on the left hand side here.
And if you were to left click on the entry, drag off and drop down,
you can see that you have three different options.
Now we're going to work with states to start with.
So if you select add state, it will add a state node.
I'm going to call this idle to run.
And the key to state machines is you can have multiple different states
and define the methods of transitioning between them.
So this will allow you to play different animations depending on what state you are in at any one time.
To begin with, we're just going to work on the idle to run.
So now that we've created this state, if you double click on it,
you'll see that we're taken to another graph.
And all that we have at this point is an output animation pose.
What I'm going to search for in my asset browser is my walk cycle.
So my BS.
You can see that I can see it here in the browser.
I will drag that in and connect that up.
Now, once this has been dragged in, you can see that we have two input pins,
speed of zero and none.
Now we can ignore the none.
However, we want the speed to be connected to the speed of the character.
And we're going to do this by using the event graph.
But to start with, we will need a variable to store this in.
So if you come up to the green input pin for speed,
right hand click, you can see at the top here, we have an option to promote to variable.
If you left click that, you can now see that we have a green variable called speed.
You will also see that we can see this in the variable section in the bottom left hand corner.
Now we need to populate this variable and we can do that from the event graph.
So I'm going to come up here and select the event graph.
Now, when you first come into the event graph, we will have one event.
And this event is the event blueprint update animation that we can see here slightly greyed out.
Now, this is effectively tick for the animation.
This is an event that will be fired by default on every frame of the game.
And this allows us to do any of the logic which will be required in order to update the animation.
I'm going to start off by using a different event.
So I'm going to drag up. I'm going to hold down the right hand mouse button and search for initialise.
And you can see at the top here we have event blueprint initialise animation.
And this won't fire as often. It will only fire at the point that we are initialising starting up the blueprint.
So this could be effectively very similar to the begin play node within blueprints.
And the reason I'm using this is because a lot of the data that I want to get hold of,
I'm going to need to get hold of from the movement component on our character.
And I want to grab and save a reference to that movement component
so that I'm not going to have to do a cast on every single frame of the game.
So under this, I'm going to do a right hand click and search for get owning actor.
And this is going to provide me with a reference to the actor which owns the skeletal mesh which this animation is playing.
And I need a reference to the movement component.
To do that, I'm going to have to cast this to the character class.
So I'll type in cast to character here.
And I'll plug that in.
So a cast is going to say, is this actor of the class character?
And if it is, do whatever is connected to this execution pin on the right here.
And you can gain access to this class from the node here.
And so what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag off of the as class.
And I am going to search for character movement.
And you will see the bottom here we have get character movement.
And this character movement is going to provide me with some of the information I need to update the animation.
So I will right hand click on the output pin and select promote to variable.
And there you go. I now have a saved reference to the character movement.
Now that's all I need to do on the Blueprint initialize animation at the moment.
So let's jump down to the event blueprint update animation.
And as I've mentioned before, this will run on tick.
So this is going to run a lot, but it's great for getting information that needs to be used for that specific animation.
So what I'm going to do is come down to the variable section and grab character movement.
Drop it in. I'm going to select and get.
So this will give me a node for character movement. And I want to calculate the speed.
So the blend space knows what animation to output.
In order to get the speed, I'm going to drag off and I'm going to get velocity.
So if I type in get velocity.
And you can see here right at the bottom, the yellow pin, we have get velocity.
And because it's a yellow pin, that means it's providing us with a vector.
So that's a struct of three floats.
And a singular float is what we need with the blend space.
So I'm going to drag off of this and I'm going to search for a node called length XY.
And that's going to give me vector length XY. I'm going to select that.
And you can see here this is returning a green pin.
So this is a float, a singular number which allows decimal points.
And so this is great. We can use this in our blend space.
So I'm going to come down to the speed, drag that in and place it over the return value.
And you'll be able to see we get a small little green tick to indicate that this would work.
I'll drop it. And now you can see that we have the speed variable.
I will plug that into the update animation.
So what we're doing here is we are getting the movement component.
We're finding out what its velocity is as a vector.
We're then calculating the length of that vector only on X and Y.
We're not interested in Z because that's up and down and we are saving that to the speed variable.
So now if I was to push compile and save and jump back into the game and run,
you would see that suddenly we have movement and the movement is dependent on the speed of our character at any one time.
And that's looking really good.
What you may have noticed is if you jump or fall, we have no animations that are connected to that at all.
That's what we're going to have a look at in the next video.